/ it's red dawn so red and Dawn's a
remake of the 1980s movie by the same
name red dawn Gillman starred Patrick
Swayze in the Warlock this new one stars
Chris Hemsworth apprentice this time as
before is the United States of America's
taken over and invaded so now it's up to
these teenagers hiding in the hills to
save the day premise sounds cool it
really does but it's all about execution
I mean I enjoyed Red Dawn back in the
day I watched it a few times I thought
it was cool not really overly attached
to the movie or anything like that so I
think a remake could be really cool only
thing is this this isn't that it's not
this isn't the cool remake you want I
just think it's really messy it's like
someone took a bunch of plot points put
them in a cup and a bunch of skirmishes
that you'll see in a movie like this you
know all the battle scenes they put them
in a cup and they threw them all on the
floor like a bunch of jacks they're like
all right yeah in that order that's
that's our movie that's what's gonna
happen so just put it on paper make it
happen and here we go we got read done
you don't care about any of the
characters the strongest character is of
course Chris Hemsworth the rest of the
characters I couldn't tell you who they
are who plays them and if they died in
the movie or not like they'll be like oh
we lost two guys back there hey Jay I
didn't take a head count or anything but
I thought you were all here I yeah at
the top of my head I can't tell who's
missing and you don't get the isolated
feeling you got in the other Red Dog you
get that feeling they were in the hills
for quite a while you know they find
that pilot and Swayze comes out all like
chief running barrel like what are you
doing here what's your name they're like
I can tell it by the way you're poised
you have leadership status my friend you
are the leader of this group aren't you
Chris Hemsworth's character in this
movie in order to establish his
dominance he always just pushed his
brother to the ground he's all think you
understand I'm like oh that's it just
kind of kicked the out of your
brother I got you that makes you the
leader that means you have leadership
quality I mean he's obviously the most
skilled out of all of them because he's
the soldier but that whole oh I don't
really get along with my brother story
arcs really gonna go nowhere in this
movie so let's just speed it along he
does not have it in there you don't care
about the characters and you don't
really feel like what they're doing
matters I mean the comedian from
Watchmen tells them like oh you guys are
really making a difference out here that
being said there is this whole middle
section of the United States that's
still actually free from oppression and
there are Marines out there in pockets
of resistance but hey you know good job
here you get the feeling that if
these kids didn't do anything at all
they're these other pockets of
resistance out there they pick up the
slack and they get the job done you
don't feel like the Maine kids in the
movie are going to single-handedly play
the most vital role in liberating the
United States you don't feel like
they're inspiring anyone no one's
writing anyone's name on a rock when
they die there's no real sacrifice and
you don't give a about any of the
characters if you're down for watching
teenagers do a couple of skirmishes in a
town well yeah that's fine it's that's
this movie knock yourself out and in the
end of this movie you'll consider this
kind of spoiler ish but I'm telling you
you shouldn't you should not give a
they're going to give a but I'm
telling you you shouldn't give a in
the end keeping it vague too like we
need to get this box and hey if they get
the box well job well done the movies
over stupid that's it so this movie has
a couple of cool things buy a couple of
cool things you're like oh that was
really cool the way that car blew up and
flipped on another car is entertaining
in the most mindless way possible filled
with characters you don't care about and
a premise it just wasn't executed very
well it's a movie of irrelevance and
really guilty pleasure if you find
pleasure in this movie I will say Red
Dawn is a good time if you're drunk yeah
now it's a party
Wolverine oh I think I threw up just now
a little bit my mouth so this is a good
question for you Red Dawn being a remake
what is your favorite remake whatever it
is comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you